or the very latest let's bring in DW
Stephon Siemens in Washington good
morning Stephon the maddest resignation
is the latest in a string of
administration departures but is this
one different it's different because
it's the utmost significant we had the
other week interior secretary Ryan sinky
resigning but he was facing an avalanche
of scandals and investigations so that
was not a real surprise but Maddie's
resigning and in this form without in
this letter you would notice not one
word of praise for the president that's
a little bit unusual normally when you
write those resignation letters to the
White House or to the president you
always say a little bit of nice things
about you former boss this one is turned
out to be a little bit of an ugly
divorce here and it is significant
because James Bennett was always seen as
the adult at the cabinet's table and as
a so-called bulwark against the most
rashes decisions of Donald Trump in
terms of foreign policy so yes matt is
leaving is significant okay now
Democrats have been among those
expressing disappointment at the
resignation here's House Minority Leader
Nancy Pelosi
I am shaken by the resignation of
general mattis for what it means to our
country for the message it sends to our
troops and for the indication of what
his view is of the commander in chief
okay this all started stuff on with
Syria how United are Democrats and
Republicans in opposing the president on
the pullout from American troops from
Syria very very United unusually so so
that is a bipartisan bipartisan front
against this decision the president made
to pull troops out of Syria Democrats as
well as the GOP the Republicans are
Moony so no saying this was the worst
idea this is a bad move the US will
we'll lose strategic and tactical
advantage in the Middle East and frankly
a lot of Republicans even Republicans
and Democrats anyway say like there is
really now without James Madison James
Madison his job as Secretary of Defense
there is not really a comprehensive
Middle East foreign policy by this
administration so Republicans and
Democrats United in their outrage and
disdain for that decision to pull troops
out of Syria okay this isn't just about
Syria though the president has also
announced that he's pulling out half of
the fourteen thousand troops in
Afghanistan as well has there been
reaction to that in Washington yeah and
the reaction is pretty much the same as
I just explained towards Syria as you
had reported earlier longest war for the
United States quite a significant death
toll in terms of a loss of American life
soldiers in this longest war however
nobody in Republican as well as
Democratic or any military planning
circles or foreign policy circles
understands why the president now is
pulling also out of out of Afghanistan
even if you just said is pulling half of
the troops out of there yes that was all
a promise from during the campaign to
bring the troops home but on the other
hand does it really make sense to leave
there the fear is here that in a few
years time the United States has to
spend more money and more effort to
bring actually troops back to clean up
after the mess which will be left after
the troops are leaving so same as since
regarding the Syria decision not no good
vibes towards the president and that
decision from Republicans and Democrats
Stephan Simon's in Washington thank you
very much for that Stefan